on Wednesday Parliament deliberated
Europe strategy for the years ahead but
forwarded last week's european council
meeting topping the debate the council's
nomination of jean-claude juncker to the
post of the president of the Commission
democracy prevailed Manvinder
fraternities v60 Princip does Madame
valid in Bergen in Aruba for the rubbish
after he in her demands did una foto
alopecia be persona non in the target
and founded on evony monsalve kiddush
pits in canada handsome and for those in
the house calling yonkers nomination and
democratic I don't understand all the
criticism that has been put forward in
saying that's not democratic the
procedure is exactly the same as David
Cameron is nominated in the British
Parliament though I don't see any got a
problem maybe some members of the House
all this talking mr. young care was
taking away from real fighter issues
kyela apartment us via it was clean when
done I additional show cam for Han and
chem forces to leave and his I'm for
unloaded prioritizing climate change and
energy were also discussed but it wasn't
long before the debate seen slipped into
what would seem to be a battle for the
coming years those in favor of further
EU integration and those not Europe has
to change a Europe that allows our
nation states to cooperate freely not a
one-size-fits-all European super-state
mr. Kamal has used I think at least 10
times the word changes in intervention
but what He is calling change I call
blocking Oh progress so yes integration
less Europe that's no change that's
regresan dear Carly
what does it mean the world can't serve
a diff so what will the next five years
bring well if we look back at what
happened at the start of the week with
the growth of your skeptic parties in
Parliament expect fireworks